[Music]
in biological clock ticking nerves dicta
submitted by Gio's people
hey the bill a woman claims her
ex-boyfriend is intentionally ruining
her chance of having babies
intentionally Geo's people that's
Mexicans bail yeah how do you
intentionally get your ex girlfriend to
not have baby you swap out the lube with
spermicide or Krazy Glue or he could
give in her sleep he could be giving her
the depo-provera shot but they're not
together right so you have to sneak in
yeah but it doesn't last like four
months the DP or what yeah
the depo-provera though so you just
sneak in like an in general he x-rays
her husband's ball sacks oh yeah she has
another man uh no babies so it's not
even the ex-boyfriend and it's an
ex-boyfriends fault why she can't have a
kid because they have frozen embryos Oh
why would you do that what they're boy
you know and then they didn't even date
for the only from 2014 to 2016 maybe you
knew the answer already we're like
trying to answer this thing you already
knew the answer [ __ ] [ __ ] right a
guess and then when you let me speak
then that's when I tell you guys the
answer so they've been together for two
years
yeah to know you well that's how long
they dated and in those two years is
when they decided because the woman
she's 42 years old oh I see
yeah and she moves faster when you're
older I get it yeah they just sorta
invest in their future yeah so they
created these these these embryos in
2015 hmm and so yeah now that they are
broken up he's actually remarried on to
his third wife and what a catch yeah and
she's trying to conceive but this dude
is preventing her from using oh I see
legally she can't deal with
is consent well I get it they did sign
an agreement where it stated that even
if they break up she is able to use
these embryos yeah legally she can use
it but what if she's like crazy and he's
like [ __ ] no I can't believe I stick my
dick and crazy and I don't want a crazy
child out but I don't get why she can't
have a baby if it's now legally she can
do it
because he's like trying to stop it from
happening like where was I - the [ __ ]
store the embryo store rushing in like
no no no don't let her have these
embryos even though it's legal that she
can and guessing she cannot naturally
get pregnant without these embryos
because like what's the stop her from
just going in a sperm bank and then
saying like you know what I'll choose
another baby daddy maybe the money that
she put in I mean she they don't explain
exactly why it has to be these embryos
that I'm assuming maybe after all that
like all of the estrogen injections and
like the whole process to just even get
those cookies pretty gnarly yeah so
we'll just let her go to court she'll
probably win and then she can do it I
don't know where I stand on this because
if I was a friend of the dude I'd be
pretty pissed off if she would want to
conceive this baby without yeah his
permission there's no father figure
yeah yeah but then back then he did sign
an agreement thing I'll let you do it
even if we break up she's 42 so you know
clock's ticking
does he still get to have
responsibilities no she's saying I don't
want any like you don't need to be
involved about it he's just been a frog
it's not realistic though because you
know once this child to get two older
the curiosity is gonna be there and
you're my daddy yeah they're gonna want
to meet it's maybe he's thinking that
far ahead to where he's like yeah I
don't have to pay for anything but this
guy or girl is gonna come track me down
in the future okay let's say let's okay
let's say you're my son and you're a
confronting me okay come come accuse me
of being your father how come how come
you didn't want to daddy me I'm not your
dad you look the same
we have I'm not your dad but we have to
get out of here there's diem on the cops
it's over that's a last conference
I'll say you just ruined this it doesn't
matter out denying what's your mother
than my mom's name
kalila never heard of her I'm gay I suck
dick that's impossible
I would do anything I can you're right
yeah I mean I was in the war my dick
came off
I have no dick down there it's like a
Barbie like a you know I can yeah yeah
yeah yeah no dick how can that happen
like I would do everything I can to deny
that he's my son so why does the car guy
care I would if kalila won't have the
baby right don't tell him about me and
then we're good maybe he's just a she
just doesn't like her like she hates her
now it's not the only way if they left
as friends I think it would have been
cool like yeah he's just trying to be
vengeful huh yeah that's probably the
case I think so so this is Alyssa who's
that the mama the woman that's trying to
use kevin costner I like it what is he
doing oh he's doing this he's a thinker
that's why he does this hmm he looks
like he likes to go tanning yeah I mean
he's the type of guy that create embryos
with the girlfriend that he's only dated
for a year good man that point when they
created these embryos is only a year on
his third marriage - on his third marry
you know what he's a Las Vegas magician
that's what he is looking at his hand
what is it cerebral palsy no there's
something going on if it's cerebral
palsy so this guy is you know there's
something going on genetically trying to
avoid having it he doesn't want his
other kids to have genetically altered
hands like that like [ __ ] hands
that's what it is
you're just looking at worry right
because if I was a detector doubt yeah
you're looking at the right thing Yeah
right I'm not looking at the face and
looking at the stuff around it it's like
penguin esta gator yeah like penguin
from Batman you know how he's all
different yeah yeah that's what it is
you know I get there like that yeah
yeah and then like what 20 years later
some kid comes up yeah you're my dad and
he has to hide his hand yeah I suck dick
it's a Cosmo are they like actors or
something I don't know what they do they
do have that actor yeah like used to be
headshots look yeah yeah she looks like
a producer writer oh yeah she looks like
to me yeah do you see her teeth you go
back to the fate and to look back to the
girl have you ever seen teeth that white
yeah that's perfect yeah so what I'm
saying here is is that you know if she
even human you already already started
singularity so look at those [ __ ]
teeth man I'm doing investigation to
journalism yeah and then what look at
that daughter on her face right have a
baby like this in a big dot on the face
like this she's good good cute baby hair
yeah she's cute she aged pretty well
yeah she's 42 slopes okay yeah look for
June the reason why she can't do it now
again is because when she froze the
embryo she was 39
so she was younger a healthier eggs and
so if she does it now then it reduces
the chances of her getting ready not she
waited till the last minute that's what
he does say it again say it again friend
she waited till the last minute oh all
right yeah what I'm saying is you had
your 20s and your 30s that's 20 years
just hear me out before you say what are
you gonna say lady because you know I'm
not done talking yet okay you will be
once there's a big window let me tell
you something if I'm in the middle of
the street for 20 years and they say
bobbie guerra the way a car's gonna hit
you and i just stood out there for 2000
hire and then 20 years later i'll
finally a car hates me who's bad is it
see but then men don't have to pause
their life in any shape or form to have
a children for instance a good example
Serena Williams has one child and she
has to forego
all the Grand Slams of that year in the
meantime Roger Federer can have
quadruplets and never miss a single
Grand Slam in his entire career
she's just being happy that she's not
washing dishes and stuff yeah she's 39
she just popped out the kids rage the
rage put in my heart I said you're
allowed to play tennis we're not making
you cook anything nine months is
allowing her what who's allowing I make
the distance I'm kidding
equal rights what do you feel that rage
you're like this is real
that's that realization I know I know
here's what I'm saying can I just say
this though you're right all right but
still in 20 years it's nine months yeah
but there are so Amend on't have to
consider timing in their life that's
true they don't have to consider be
making sure that the vessel that the
baby grows in is healthy we don't have
to comment and what'll ya have consider
actually staying home and caring and
rearing that child yeah all right Bobby
what I'm saying is is that you can do
whatever you want to do but you can't
have it all yeah but maybe that was a
time where she was like you know what my
career is finally a part you better back
me up I sorta [ __ ] God man
no you're alone on this yeah yeah where
are you that guy has cerebral palsy so
you're saying this same that she just
back to the point that she had 20 years
I understand that she has to sacrifice
may be she didn't have 20 years what she
is 42 right yeah but I mean maybe in
those 20 years the timing was just not
there because she's probably building
her life and she okay fine it appears
the thing is is that build your life
right have a career like playing money
make more than men I don't care you
probably deserve it lady
they're probably gifted but don't have a
baby you're saying planner better no
don't have a baby
you chose a career
you're saying I don't have the right to
change my mind at 39 and say you know
what I finally feel like I can do this
huh you're saying I don't have that
right as a woman you have the right but
then go ahead at 40 to have one I can't
because it's all bad you just saying be
responsible for your choices you you're
42 right and you're like I did until now
she did kind of night and she did create
these embryos she did yeah yeah I hear
what you're saying and I and I would
agree to an extent like yeah you want to
plan for it and yes kalila you're right
like everyone does have a right you know
to change your minds or whatever and
that's what she did and and good for her
that she lives in a time when she has
the option to do that but I'm fortunate
for her she just partnered up with the
wrong [ __ ] person that's really what
it is yeah I shouldn't pick the [ __ ]
wedding singer not a Vegas magician what
what is it yeah with my trouble for I'm
sorry say sorry I'm sorry baby
I'm wrong not just to me too well I'm
sorry too women all over the world if
you're 80 you should be a blob of baby
yeah if you're Janet Jackson at 50 yeah
you cannot to have a baby right the
cerebral palsy and thing on your face
[Music]